i was really shocked when i woke up and
learned that a real friend of the show
and a guy i loved and admired taylor
hawkins
who was the drummer as you know from foo
fighters who has been on this show a
million times going back it was recently
on the show recently
so i can't tell you how sad i was when i
woke up after this guy has been on the
show so many times i thought um he
looked like a rock star he had
everything he had the talent he was an
excellent drummer he had that long
blonde hair like a surfer and this
taylor hawkins i always had a great
feeling about i know robin did for a
different rock i thought he was a great
i loved him i thought he was so cool and
so sweet i'll play a couple of clips
from the times that he was on but first
i'm gonna go to you robin when you were
drooling the first time we uh met him
this was back in 1998 robin was just
carrying on it was almost embarrassing
here we go you call them beavers the
coffee room and amy and i said who's the
guy with a blonde hair yeah you must get
laid every night right being a drummer
and the foo fighters and then like you
know being cute shirt off oh yeah right
does he drum with the shirt off never
seen him drawing with a shirt on that is
the coolest move if i had anything close
to a physique i would do this never seen
it with a shirt on and he was a selfless
kind of guy and i base it on this there
was a time when um i had asked dave to
come in and sing acoustically
i think it was the time he did there
goes my hair there goes my hero
[Music]
and um taylor was with him dave's
sitting there playing the guitar on the
couch and taylor's sitting next to dave
and he was being so supportive of dave
and even though taylor wasn't in the
spotlight he was just like man my lead
singer the guy who writes all the songs
for the foo fighters is sitting here
playing the guitar and i'm just going to
sit back and take it all in because it's
pretty great
goes my hero
watching as he goes
here's a an example of how much dave
grohl and taylor liked each other right
from the start their friendship was one
of the great partnerships in rock music
and
uh here you go the day we met it was
like
long-lost brothers right definitely
best friends and have a good connection
musically and right you know when we're
on stage i probably spend most of the
time focused on taylor right dave grohl
was of course the drummer in nirvana
he's considered one of the greatest
drummers of all time so people are
always asking taylor is it intimidating
to play drums in dave grohl's band and
this is what he said the only time i get
really like nervous when or not or antsy
is when we're recording new music
because
um
you know he's such a great drummer he
could obviously do it himself so i have
to sit
in there with the headphones and make
them happy which is hard but it's not
hard
he's not never a dick about it really
honestly i can honestly say that he's
never a dick about it but um it's
intimidating there's no question when i
joined the band i was
super intimidated because you know i met
axel rose the first time and he said
what's it like being the drummer for the
greatest drummer of the 90s i'm like oh
hard
yeah that's what he said to me i was
like whoa axel rose and he said that and
i'm like oh and dave always believed in
taylor as a drummer they met when taylor
was playing drums for alanis mara set
she had a touring band she put together
and that's what taylor was doing dave
needed a drummer for the foo fighters
and taylor fit right in even in 1999
dave was sure his partnership with
taylor would last he offered to pay me
if he ever fired taylor that's how much
he i would never throw taylor out of
this i will never throw taylor out of
this band
save that tape save the table let me
watch
out of the band you give me ten thousand
ten thousand all right do me a favor
though do you wanna tell me the truth do
you okay twenty grand thank you twenty
five do you ever record over what taylor
did no
the friendship the loyalty went both
ways
uh this is what taylor said in argentina
last week at the band's last show before
he died this is uh taylor talking i
[ __ ] love dave grohl man
i'd be delivering pizzas if i wasn't the
[ __ ] dave girl
i'd be managing
the drum department at a guitar center
if it wasn't for dave grohl
anyway uh i'll give you an example of
his drumming in 2021 the band played all
my life on this show at the end of the
song taylor went crazy on the drums and
i thought it was great
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
pretty good
and you uh
it's sad i sit there and i go oh god all
that talent
all that work he put in
to get that good
another guy's gun and
and you just don't you don't get that
good without dedication in fact taylor
once told me how he obsessed about music
and how obsessed he needed to be in
order to get to that level of being a
great musician when all you guys were
kids did you just sit in your rooms and
play over and over and over again was it
really just an obsession did it take
thousands and thousands of hours of
practice you know it wasn't just the
playing it was the looking at the
records and looking inside the records
and looking at the drum sets and looking
at the stages and
it was kind of all-encompassing for me i
mean i just
once rock and roll was
it there was nothing else
nothing else well and girls and girls of
course
don't forget so uh with the foo fighters
they would go on stage and dave grohl
would go on the drums and taylor would
sing a queen song
i got a tape here from argentina on
march 20th
this is their last show and this is a
taylor doing a little bit of somebody to
love you know the queen song yeah
yeah can you find
me
[Applause]
can you find me
somebody
somebody too
[Music]
somebody
[Applause]
[Music]
anyway he's gone and i'm sad
i haven't stopped thinking about it
[Music]
it's the sweetheart
[Music]
me